les chéris on va regarder tout de suite
hatem ben arfa et mokhtar c'est en deux
parties franchement c'est ouf
hatem voilà si l'on regarde on s'excuse
encore à dorothée mme fort et greg
guillotin s'excuse et bien d'autres
il est adorable jusqu'à un certain point
regardez hatem ben arfa tg par guillotin
ebook tard c'est parti c'est la première
partie
[Musique]
là
mr
excaver ont permis
hatem qu'elle visite des serres et les
quads m
je sais que moi moi j'adore toujours
autant la nouveauté
mc non bonjour qui atteint matin c'est
donc à l'échelle jeu juste prendre des
marchés à thème pardon je vais prendre
j'ai pris des notes de ton dossier et a
pris des notes
en fait c'est parce que je vais
t'expliquer moi à la base je suis pas du
tout footballeur a touché connaît que
dalle h les dimanches toute façon j'ai
pas joué par un respect énorme au
footballeur je le préfère parler en
toute transparence a tardé mais qui
courent après un ballon tout cas c'est
mon ami si ça c'est mon ami mais comment
fait on a une situation de crise pour
moi donc clairement tu étais rentré dans
une zone rouge est par contre ouais
excuse moi
excuse moi en fait c'est clair que là on
a une situation de crise pour moi
terrain cas critique aujourd'hui motards
m'a parlé un peu de toi
de fait que là tu jouais plus trop en ce
moment est où ton cas et les graves
n'ont ils pas de là j'ai pas vu les
membres de distinction de quatre mois
dit à vue du patron mythique revient pas
un crime c'est hatem atavique ada je
suis trompé de talent mais là j'ai je
suis ok c'est complexe mais bon j'aime
bien motard je suis je viens trop de
services que moi parce que ça rapporte
aloi non mais déjà il faut savoir que
moi j'ai rien demandé énormément de
coups bas les pattes expliqué l'instant
mon tarif ce matin qu'une multitude
enfin tu m'attaques spiritueux pas pour
moi ya pas de différence entre un
sportif et un chanteur vous êtes des
produits pour moi tu vois des produits
comment jeunes et des frontignes pour
moi vous êtes des produits c'est-à-dire
si je vous tends la main tu vois je te
jette un gilet de sauvetage
suivez vous n'avez salon le forum voilà
je sais pas si notre tarte à parler de
moi de ce que j'ai réussi un peu les
gens que j'ai fait un peu brillé que je
vais revenir un peu dans la lumière
rémy qui ya félicien du loft la caf et
la cum cum mania tu t'en souviens des
travaux de l'îlot story nous sommes le
premier à félicien et part sur un autre
titre là s'est il n'ya pas il n'y a pas
que les écureuils qui aiment les glands
saint lô
bah c'est drôle mais c'est dans les
clubs échangistes pour va essayer de le
propulser
mais c'est si non tu t'énerves
réceptionner les dons je vais juste
autre lettre de seconde il a soufflé ses
toiles à de mauvaises équipes à défiler
ce 13 mai dont qui donc tu m'a dit je
veux juste qu'on sévèrement pour
discuter aussi les gg 1 j'ai des gens
dans mon entourage qui sont assez bien
placé aussi parce que j'ai fait jouer
des contacts mais ça je t'en parle pour
toi est ce que tu penses vraiment et
j'ai besoin qu'il sert à moossou je
pense qu'aujourd'hui adapte à apprendre
les services et sur ton à ton agent on
va le dégager mon agent il fait du
mauvais travail
parce que sinon ce n'est pas là en fait
un joueur comme toi ça devrait pas être
sur le banc aujourd'hui je vais rentrer
dans le vif du sujet aujourd'hui ça me
fait chier que toi tu sois sur le bord
ok c'est vrai que tu as des jambes tu as
tu cours vite même si j'ai vu que tu te
donnais pas forcément toujours un fond
sur les matches parce que j'ai regardé
quelques vidéos et pour moi il ya des
problèmes de jeu tu vois je vois
toujours les délais mais qu'ils ont tout
le temps plein ils sont ils sont plein
de sueur et tout quand il court vu le
naufrage dans la lutte et le tiers
commence à se dire
on évoque c'est un déchet mais se
réveille des envies van sant et occupe
vraiment tu vois michel échec le
problème dans ta carrière c'est ça que
tu fais que de rigoler il prend pas les
choses ainsi règle a appelé par son
prénom à thème moi ce qu'on me dit
aujourd'hui la pression que j'ai c'est
c'est hatem ben arfa aujourd'hui il a
une image de fils de
[Musique]
bollard on s'était parlé à l'école tu
vois que j'ai versé un troupeau c'est
parti enfin tu sais pas très bien
exprimer j'ai créé bien l'esprit mais
jai quoi les studios s'étaient déjà
prêté à d'école
après je dois je me sens un petit peu
concernés mais tu es tu vois ce que je
veux aller footballeurs pour moi ça le
football
ben non ça pour moi c'est déjà dans la
tête et c'est ça que je veux qu'ils ont
été exaucées bien sûr mais tu sais avec
tous mes articles je fais comme ça et
j'ai pas de temps à perdre
une image peu tassé je pense qu'à la
thune et je joue tous les matchs
moi j'en utilise votre argent je m'en
fous je vibrais pour le ballon peu
importe si on ne paye plus intense mood
ces jeux subtils à la phrase que
j'aimerais qui buzz sur les réseaux
sociaux
j'en ris et je suis bénard pas le joueur
gratos hier
d'ailleurs je suis gratos et toujours
avec le sourire
dire qu'on va faire des sous et on va
faire des juifs on va faire des trucs
comme ça on va faire plein plein de
choses avec ton effigie cas le sourire
avec l'équipe ben arfa le joueur gratos
ensuite j'ai pensé à un geste c'est ça
c'est vraiment ça va faire rire les gens
et on me servir à fonctionner un but
quand tu es devant les journalistes
c'est ça c'est l'argent du main et le
seuil non comme ça c'est de l'argent
j'en veux pas et tu marques un but tu
cours tu fais comme ça je repas de votre
avant je veux pas d'enveloppés d'argent
il reste en poste regarde c'est archi
faux
il faut que mon très vite fait j'ai un
graphiste qui m'a fait ça comme ça tu
manques c'est le refus de l'argent nous
mener nous mener pour moi quoi tu vois
deuxièmement je t'explique est déjà dans
les tic persuadé qu'il sait
disait comme quoi il y avait une rumeur
le moyen âge est non
c'est une information importante que
j'aime recevoir à l'instant par un crs
d'une source assez proche d'hatem ben
arfa est manifestement bien informée
steve indique que hatem ben arfa serait
sur le point de vue qu'il connaissait
bien le foot la seu ce qui n'a pas
incroyable à la deuxième partie qui
m'arrive et je voulais je voulais couper
en deux parce que c'est énorme ici un
hiver bien fait on s'y croirait quoi ah
oui il est extraordinaire lui
heureusement qu'il est bien éduqué mais
là sinon c'est un amour aller très très
vite
quelle voiture à revoir comme ça ce que
je lui dis des mots tels ben arfa il a
une image de fdp
ouais j'aurais peut-être fait jusque là
n'a pas été à l'école le faut vous en
mêlez coup de vieux clichés à l'école
boulle un footballeur t'as rien dans la
tête et c'est impossible
la plupart des footballeurs sont très
intelligents giuly ne s'élève pas et
quitte pas la pièce a dormi exception on
peut parler du loukoum a fait pas j'ai
jamais vu quelqu'un d'aussi dégueulasse
ouest 20 mais pour vraiment ça a été
très très loin cette affaire vous auriez
réagi vous je sais pas gilles ma machine
lorsque je pète les plombs et chaoui
benjamin mélanome et moi joker agathe
vous qu'il connaissait bien le foot à
tête c'est un amour un ah oui il est
très très gentil mais là ouais le pot je
me mets à sa place cinq minutes ça a dû
être aujourd'hui l'audience qu'il faille
à le flash info sport là qu'ils
l'annoncent dans un autre club mais
c'est ça ce sera dans un instant puisque
hatem ben arfa on a été très très très
très loin avec lui on a même été jusqu'à
enregistrer infoflash impôt sur la
chaîne sur la vraie chaîne s'était
surpassé c'était sur infosport
donc on vraiment remercier nos amis
d'infosport tout même fait un débat sur
la rive et d'hatem ben arfa
vous allez voir ça quant à l'instant
dans la grande race ra3 avec guillotin
avec lothar et avec ce triste